[Musica]
benvenuti salito oggi a grandissima
richiesta al nuovo video in cui faremo
tantissimi scherzi super divertenti alla
maestra cattiva mazzieri teacher di
simili video vi facciamo discorsi
scritti già mi sono piaciuti ma se ve li
siete persi andati a vederli poi dopo
questo video perché fanno super ribes a
volta andremo a tingere i capelli a
bruciare i vestiti divertenti quindi mi
raccomando lasciato un bel mi piace
questo video se volete vedere un altro
episodio in cui facciamo tanti che si
terr it is all anzhi consenso dei
commenti quali altri giochi il momento
che vendiamo e non avete visto discorsi
video qui facciamo noi di scherzi ha
costruito un parco giochi per berlino in
giardino dove vederli poi dopo questo
video e alla fine del video scriveteci
nei commenti qual è lo scherzo che vi ha
divertito più di tutti anche noi vi
diremo il nostro preferito ma mettetevi
solo di vedere di napoli è tenuto il
primo scherzo riguardi attrezzi il
vestito di script icer così non andrà al
suo party mascherato perché non può
permettersi di divertirvi giudizio con
fatica attiva
[Musica]
una scoperta a cerci ha corso alcun
motore è rete dice cosa dovrei
incrostare al party mascherato da tanto
mi sta bene il tutto
l'uomo del fiume lo vediamo il vestito
penso che abbiamo varie possibilità
secondo me potremmo tagli arie lo
potremo punto cruciale
oppure potremmo prenderlo buttando in
piscine non misuro gli abbiamo tolto
addosso che si formerà broker ora
dobbiamo semplicemente trovare dove
scrissi sul nasconde il vestito immagino
che sia al piano di sopra per clienti
sopra alla sua stanza in realtà ne ha
tantissime distanze dobbiamo trovare la
camera da letto hanno fatto vedere non
l'ho vista io dove stava dobbiamo stare
attenti a fornire le camere di sicurezza
mi raccomando ragazzi guardate nel
remoto più nuovo per noi quello in
armadio che ho visto no non c'è niente
perché negli armadi o che lei in bagno
che cos'è questo un altro armadio un po
strano abbiamo un po di tempo prima che
arrivi facciano formativi forse qua ma
questo vestito bari torino
questa risalita è qua c'è un altro
armadio riproviamo che presentano un
ottimo mentre stava scappando
ma è bruciata ok arrivato al riparo da
occhi di sky non vedo l'ora di vedere
dopo che vedi qui abbiamo tagliato
investito domenica giorno di fronte a
papa
eccola senza vicenda in titoli di milano
reazione bollette tutta la bambina bravi
allora prossimo il terzo metti uno
spillone di mano così buggerare teacher
il deb enea mentre molto prima che
cattivi
mi piace molto il tema
ok abbiamo capito prima troviamo uno
spillo da mettere in vendita la diamo a
distrarre gli dice anche perché questi
avete consigliato di suonare il
campanello ti ha bisogno se scende le
scale to cercano guardano come c'è
scritto copre il pid per nasconderlo
bene allora dove abbiamo messo proprio
qui di fronte al tema macchine
preoccupare lo scrive partecipazione
fregato creta in casa si battevano il
prossimo è stato sono per sempre critici
la cattiveria scrittice confini quindi
devi liberare il povero gatto che lei ha
rinchiuso razzi o service che rivincere
non si richiudono i gatti zitto il
pubblico gatto di tito rocco per sempre
merita tantissimi scherzi cattivi adesso
scheri tce merlino ciononostante sempre
migratori che dormiva dove sarò al gatto
che il napoli è molto vicino anche voi
[Musica]
meglio che continua vitale e vi
presentiamo a trovare questo povero
gatto c'è una porta li possa mangiare ma
che pensiamo siamo anno ma se facciamo
terme giu era pro natura di sotto
cerchiamo nelle dieci milioni di fans
guardate il mio giornata ha detto perché
noi abbiamo da vendere ha cambiato il
vestito è dipinta
ecco lo zero ma dentro guarda
prendi le buche carino scriveva 12
caparco si fece scappare dalla finestra
tra l'altro vicino bastevole il prossimo
terzo il momento di rovinare il
compleanno di spiriti cercato di rubarle
qualche gioco così come lei ha fatto a
tutti i bambini nella scuola quindi
falle esplodere la torta con dei fuochi
d'articifio queste si piace tanto ci
piace tanto per il problema di scherzi
se secondo voi quanti anni farà secondo
me 190
ecco la torta c'era una candela blu
dobbiamo trovare quindi i fuochi
d'artificio per farli esplodere la torta
che dobbiamo mettere dentro la torta i
fuochi d'artificio che per carlo lava
maggiore di librizzi stima con la sua
torta giusta tanto allora come al solito
prendiamo questo per entrare ma non
poteva rimanere sul divano
anzi prestissimo si trova ora basta solo
entrare metterli nella torto farle
esplodere scappare proprio libero
alessia morando la tv ma facchetti ecco
le colora di stroke potremo entrare di
capire se ci riusciamo vicino al camino
siamo un attimo tesi è meglio che si
spostano ok ok di sopra di stagione
f mette poi prendiamo questo possiamo
sembrare uguale troppo farla sembrare
una candela o di relazioni
[Musica]
ora che stava cantando sia pure a se
stessa che siamo molto divertiti ma
scherza allora insegna una lezione
ascheri teacher che non dimenticherà mai
metti in radio nel suo libro una verità
vediamo
ok anno nel libro preferito è qui dove
sappiamo ma c'era lei nella bibbia
svizzeri antichissimo suo preferito
c'è scritto di trovare l'anima di stare
attenti perché morte
guardatevi si sa truccato anche migliori
molto dallo scantinato è questo questa è
la via più semplice per raggiungere
sinistra un corso soia così non va bene
una trappola anche qua basta arrivato
con fuori più belli non molto no per ora
no perché non è facile prenderlo nostro
sole dita ha preso la trappola vitale
quindi li potrebbe avvicinarsi da un
momento all'altro vediamo che cosa
cercate qui ma dovessero addirittura si
chiama ragazzi quello una macchinina
aspettata
immagino che inizierà a correre in bagno
che si sta pettinando che dice sempre
che lei ha dei capelli di ministri che
sono tutti i giorni ma ok scorciatoia
[Musica]
personaggio guarda cos'è
quando ti senti ma forse per non farsi
mordere per primi dobbiamo ancora
trovare la perché diceva che il ragno
morte si no e se davvero di tutto
dobbiamo portare questo ragno che non
troviamo ne sono parte come si apre così
forte non è servito anche i boati che
brevetta veterana dobbiamo portarlo il
mio metterlo nel suo libro è più vero
insomma non mi riporto io vi parlo non
era proprio lì infatti adesso vede dai
ragazzi se non sappiamo titolare pure lo
scherzo più difficile che cosa stiamo a
sfruttare un tavolo sul tavolo questo
libro ecologici che sia questo si no
questi sono gli ski cioccolatini di
cioccolatini nomi circolati fidati non
esperto scappiamo li ha creati sopra
quindi ovviamente prodotti capaci
nascondiamo qui e sicuri non c'è bisogno
di sir è fuori dalla casa la prima mai
corretti
poi differente non carcerato nuovo video
non è permesso
ecco prossimo scherzo scritti e molto
ossessionata dai suoi capelli quindi le
fa più male di testa al senso sì
qualcosa sul bomber rovinato sia abbiamo
ok richiesta facendo il bagno o di apiro
parabalani sta preparando le ho letto
che per questo scherzo si sono vari
possibili scenari ma se quello che
andremo ad aggiungere allo shampoo c'è
tipo possiamo farle parlare i capelli
possiamo colorarli è un'altra cosa che
mi incorrono sembra fargli di tutti i
dritti doloranti e divertente che
l'orario capelli di visti forse abbiamo
un po di tempo in più sì perché stiamo
vivendo l'energia
quindici le energie del gioco di sì
andare vento lento lento finché non bevi
una di quelle lattine vi si è bloccata
libero stacca mia morosa possiamo agire
il visto pane formaggio e allora che
cosa abbiamo coloranti direi di mettere
il colorante poi li c'e un'altra cosa ma
deve dimettere il colorante che lo
shampoo e metterla nella vasca forse non
lo prendeva un round di giorni possiamo
scappare di qua difficile speriamo che
ci caschi vediamo vidi un video saluto
involge speriamo che funzioni
ecco
ma anche la frutta giuliano sangue
[Musica]
davanti dice che abbiamo fallito lo
scherzo perché lei è molto contenta con
il nuovo colore di capelli infatti ha
detto no sto bene con qualsiasi colore
dovrebbe essere il legale essere così
bello quindi dobbiamo in realtà le usare
l'altro che o perché li fa i capelli
dritti oppure quello che la pop e la sua
foto campeggia torna a rivedere spiriti
serve ora lei sta per uscire da lì
quindi dobbiamo stare qui per te sono
molto curioso di vedere se anche da
pelata dirà che lei è bellissima cosa
bagno gravissimo se sia arrivato nel
bagno
dobbiamo prendere questo l'altro questo
il mood che vuol dire che tutti i
capelli quindi noi che siamo qui giusto
però deve scappare io scappo di qua come
l'altra volta bravo di me lo sai
eccolo sta arrivando proprio arrivando
comunque questo costo bergamo
[Musica]
e stato visto lo spirito si per capelli
adesso è sempre la furono da mismo
troppo simpatica tiratissimo medico non
è stato il nostro scherzo preferito
permette ultimo fatta di noi tantissimo
ma anche il bagno la divertente ma a me
è piaciuto quello della porta e del
fuoco d'artificio dovesse dire sì
pubblica per vedere i miei altri video e
come al solito cliccate su quella di
preferite